sadness bewilderment anger and the
world's attention concentrated itself at
the Brussels home of Europe's elected
deputies the nuclear option many feared
Britain would follow but hoped they
wouldn't now a reality
the line of the European Parliament is
quite clear we are very sad about the
decision of the voters in the United
Kingdom but it is a sovereign expression
of the will of British voters to leave
the European Union this is a difficult
moment for both sides group leaders met
early to discuss reactions and next
steps concerning a withdrawal according
to EU treaty Britain will stay in the EU
for two years after the official
notification of its withdrawal as he
Montevideo repay it if it is to summon
about NAFTA some continent it is a
trolley guitar Gandhi now enticed by me
evicted is Thunder striking does faster
helped the Britons if you're open and
she'd not Timmy's mouth paroxetine
wounds his victims as we under strike
him the weak tin are Apogee mines I'm
didn't metropolis yet melt this is a
Vegas fee directly in Simon's von
sieglin de turista giving Misano molto
triste ma question on a elfanara della
ropa de una she'll take a respect e amo
el gouna she'll take a Jew de camões
Beata Maria G Remo no real answer a
Munna forced offensive a political pair
responder i problema de cheated in
Europe a OG&E Cesario salvar la ropa
cambian Dora a Rendon Dora Multipure
micachina cheated even the British
people have spoken they voted to leave I
think is important that one of our
personal views were that we respect the
democratic were the British people now's
the time for us all to pull together and
move on for the first time in history
after wave after wave of expansion the
EU now shrinks 27 members no more 28 the
decision of the British citizens to
leave the European we were very clear
this and the discussion of nearly more
than 40 years with obtains opt-outs
rebates earmarks you name it who has
made
difficulties in union then give her
solutions but we have to be serious
about it the best way to react to this
outcome of this referendum is not
business as usual but is to start an
in-depth reform of European youth there
were fears - for the peace process in
Ireland happily feel fine and close
battalion each tank oh my god all are
not Ireland aligned the fourth day long
does the Republic Ireland under northern
Finland Tunbridge and I was in
Connecticut went where the trustee has
and catastrophic offered in three
quarters in not Elan been the atala hue
body and I don't dare Britain does is
fewer the over pho onion analyst attack
Lord VHD does thank me Muslims a chef
Hagen vast mafia I fired the sphere
niched
de Mia heightened and Anna's ocean
abdomen but so ignored at us even under
the foreign Hospital in Hobart showing
during the economic and refugee trials
of the past years the EU has attempted
often failed to act together now more
than ever that will be the ambition -
one